thank you for coming here it's so nice
of you all I'm Washington to take time
out of your busy schedules of ruining
America to be here this evening I will
also alert you that we are we are on the
we are on the record here we're on tape
for our friends at c-span which um is
one of my favorite channels actually
because you know during the nominating
conventions the only channel where you
can watch the actual convention in its
entirety without you know some pundit
yakking and you can see the convention
actually happening over his shoulder you
know c-span just shows you the you know
the speech I borrow actually though in
my favorite moment of that whole week
all the other cable lacquers the first
morning of the of the Democratic
National Convention all cable news was
out was a bunch of various Talking Heads
talking about what Hillary Clinton might
maybe possibly say and on and then I
flipped as he spent and it was the it
was a it was empty chairs on a silent
stage for like a minute in half because
they were waiting for the people who are
going to say something to show up its
dignified
there's sometimes there's something that
like dead air is fresh air which I say
as preface to you know my own yakking
here the only thing more dangerous than
an idea is a belief and by dangerous I
don't mean thought-provoking I mean
might get people killed
take the Reverend John cotton in 1630 he
goes down to the port of Southampton to
preach a farewell sermon to the 700 or
so colonists of the Massachusetts Bay
Company led by Governor John Winthrop a
gentleman farmer and lawyer these mostly
Puritan dissenters are about to sail
from England to New England on the
flagship Arbella and ten other vessels
in the Winthrop fleet by the time cotton
says Amen he has fought Mexico for Texas
bought Alaska from the Russians and
dropped napalm on Vietnam then he lays a
wreath on Custer's grave and revs past
Wounded Knee then he claps when the
Marquis de Lafayette tells Congress that
someday America will save the world then
he smiles when Abraham Lincoln calls the
United States the last best hope of
Earth then he frees Cuba which would be
news to Cuba then he signs the lease on
Guantanamo Bay cotton sermon is titled
God's promised to his plantation he
begins with one of the loveliest
passages from the book of second Samuel
another right otherwise r-rated
chronicle of King David serial-killer
years probably not the best thing to say
on Yom Kippur um
chapter 7 verse 10 I will appoint a
place for my people Israel and I will
plant them that they may dwell in a
place of their own and move no more and
sound so homey like that column in the
real estate section of the New York
Times about how people found their
apartments till I remember the talk like
this is the match still lighting the
fuses of a thousand car bombs what
cotton is telling me is about to be
Americans it's that they are God's new
chosen people this they like to hear in
fact they have been telling themselves
just that the Old Testament Israelites
are - the Puritans what the blues was -
the Rolling Stones a source of
information a renewable resource of
riffs what cotton is telling them is
that like the Old Testament Jews they
are men of Destiny and like the Old
Testament Jews God has given them a new
home a promised land and like the Old
Testament Jews God has printed eviction
HUD has printed eviction notices for
them to tack up on the homes of the
nothing special just folks folks who are
squatting there it's fine according to
cotton to move into a country not
altogether void of inhabitants if said
country is really big
after all he continues Abraham and Isaac
when they sojourned amongst the
Philistines they did not buy that land
to feed their cattle because they said
there is room enough this is God's
plantation remember cotton says if God
be the gardener who shall pluck up what
he sets down here that Indians no
weeding of the white people allowed
unless they're Catholic are one of those
satan-worshipping Virginians John cotton
is 46 years old he is the most respected
famous and beloved Puritan minister in
England getting him to bless the
send-off of these relatively unimportant
castaways would be like scouring Nelson
Mandela to deliver the commencement
address at the neighbor kids 8th grade
graduation in fact once the colonists
arrived in Massachusetts they will name
their settlement Boston in
of Cotton's hometown these people
listening to this man are scared there's
a boat in the harbor that just might
sail them to their deaths they may never
see their friends again until heaven or
hell depending on how this dumb plan
goes for years they've grumbled that
England is a cesspool governed by an
immoral king under the spell of the
[ __ ] of Babylon which is their cute
nickname for the Pope but now that it's
time to light out their dear old mother
country seem so cozy all warm beds and
warm beer and days of auld lang syne yet
here is the smartest man in England
maybe the smartest man in the world
telling them little owed them that they
have been picked by God they are
Israelites as what they are they are
fleeing Egypt good riddance
next stop land of milk / honey now they
know they can do this they can vomit
their way across the sea they can spend
ten years digging up tree stumps to plow
frozen fields they can even learn to
love corn for the first time in months
they can breathe I'm going to skip ahead
a little bit so much happens that you're
going to miss out on right now
oh I'm just looking at it oh the
encouragement of literature the name my
friend has for his card drive that
derives from the out cries of Giles
Corey as he was being executed in Salem
you'll just have to look it up later now
I'm moving on to a to John Winthrop who
is also standing there legend has it
Winthrop wrote and delivered his sermon
a model of Christian charity on the
Arbella
in the middle of the Atlantic in 1630
some scholars now contend he wrote it in
England and delivered it back in
Southampton before shoving off perhaps
on the very same occasion as Cotton
preached his farewell sermon God's
promised to his plantation if that
Winthrop cotton double bill is true the
only thing that would make the program a
more exceptional event in the history of
American exceptionalism is if Theodore
Roosevelt showed up to conduct a brassy
version of America the Beautiful
performed by the United States Marine
Corps band reading Cotton's God's
promise to his plantation alone hence
that deceit dissenting English
Protestants had plenty of where God's
special chosen people talked to go
around so maybe went through co-opting
the image of a city on a hill from the
Gospel of Matthew was just one more
metaphor for the pile maybe that was the
hill the city would be built on a
teetering stack of self-congratulatory
biblical comparisons because of the city
upon a hill soundbite a model of
Christian charity is one of the
formative documents outlining the idea
of America but dig deep into its
communitarian ethos and it reads like an
America that might have been America
fervently devoted to the quaint goals of
working together and getting along
of course this America does exist it's
called Canada
every settler on the Winthrop fleet
automatically became more important more
necessary just by leaving England that
is true for Winthrop most of all in
Massachusetts he will be governor the
highest authority in the land in England
he is at best a middling sort an average
member of the land owning gentry he is a
justice of the peace in his run of the
mill County in East Anglia he is only
friends with members of parliament not a
member himself and if he had ambitions
to become an MP they were surely dashed
when Charles the first scrapped
parliament altogether that's one of the
things you dismissed that was a big
hubbub wind rips friends in the
Massachusetts Bay Company were shrewd
talent scouts who saw something in
Winthrop some potential greatness and
recruited him to emigrate and become
their CEO Winthrop sees the faith of his
peers as a revelation of God's calling
when a man is made to wade through a
deep water wrote Winthrop when he was
mulling over the move there is required
tallness think about that on Election
Day this contradiction between humility
before God and the egomania
unleashed by being chosen by God is true
of both Winthrop and the colony of
Massachusetts itself this man hopes for
tallness for himself as well as for his
future city pitched in his mind above
sea level on yonder Hill it is no
accident that Winthrop speaks of God
Almighty in his most holy and wise
Providence at the sermon start the
English Puritans were obsessed with the
idea of Providence and that word is more
ominous to them than it sounds to us it
means care but it also means control it
does not just mean that God will provide
it means God will provide whatever the
hell God wants and the Puritans will
thank him for it even if he provides
them with nothing more than a slow death
in a long winter it means
if they're scared and small and lowly
enough he just might toss a half eaten
corn cob their way it means that the
world isn't fair and it's their fault it
means that God is the sovereign the
authority
it means manna from heaven but it also
means bow down Winthrop and his fellow
Calvinists believed in the doctrine of
predestination did you know I learned
from my friend Heron that there's no
sign for Calvinism things are really
going to hell in this country you know
Winthrop and his fellow Calvinists
believed in the doctrine of
predestination since God decides
everything God decides whether a person
will end up in heaven or hell before the
person is even born the people who are
going to heaven are called the elect but
here's the thing how does anyone know
how does anyone know if he's saved
you can't what he can do is work try
believe repent love God and hate himself
the diligent hard-working and pious are
the visible Saints if a person seemed
saved odds are he is saved thus he will
spend every waking hour trying to seem
saved
let's hazard a guess that some people
are not going to be up for this the
constant uncertainty in his journal
Windsor writes the following about an
acquaintance who is driven mad by
spiritual doubt and took action to
decide her fate once and for all
he wrote a woman of Boston congregation
having been in much trouble of mind
about her spiritual estate at length
grew into other desperation and could
not endure to hear of any comfort etc so
as one day she took her little infant
and threw it into a well and then came
into the house and said now she was sure
she would she should be damned for she
had drowned her child
that's how heavy the weight of Calvinism
can be that a mother would seek relief
in murdering her own
offspring but for John Winthrop and the
men and women like him this way of life
is a stirring challenge a thrilling
project and sometimes even a joy
tallness yep early so much to do never
bored reflect over think repent and his
sermon a true sight of sin Thomas Hooker
rebels in the effort of self-examination
a half-hearted Christian sits in a
comfortable chair and peruses his own
sins by his fireside and happily reads
the story of these in a book a true
Calvinist on the other hand is a kind of
war correspondent on the move one who
has passed through many countries of
barrenness and meanness and Witness ruin
and desolation by going to the trouble
of taking a hard look at his own crimes
against God the Calvinist knows what sin
is and what it hath done how it has made
havoc of his peace and made him a terror
to himself which to these people is a
good thing this is the terror that keeps
the sinner awake to his own shortcomings
and with fear comes adrenaline and a
spiritual diary
Winthrop started keeping in 1606 he
wrote a pious to-do list on May 23rd
1613 he was 26 he pledges to God that he
will carefully avoid vain and needless
expenses he promises to diligently
observe the Lord Sabbath to try and keep
his mornings free for private prayer
meditation and reading he will flee
idleness and much worldly business he
will often pray with my wife and the
first time I read that I wonder where
I'd seen it before and I realized it was
at the end of the Great Gatsby the great
novel of ambition
after the striving title character meets
his tragic end his father arrives from
Minnesota for the funeral bringing with
him a book in which his son had
inscribed a list of his ambitions as a
youth there is a rigid schedule that
begins with getting up early and filling
the day with work exercise and study
from 5:00 until 6:00 p.m. he is to
practice elocution
boys and how to attain it then in a list
of general resolves he orders himself to
quit smoking and wasting time read one
improving book or magazine per week set
money aside and be better to parents
Gatsby's father tells Gatsby's friend
the list proves that his boy was bound
to get ahead sure his son had just died
in a swimming pool but at least it was a
very fancy pool the ambition and toil
Calvinism requires will lead the
economist Max Weber to coin the term
Protestant work ethic to describe the
Puritans legacy of rolled-up sleeves
tireless labor and ambition in pursuit
of salvation he opined led to a culture
of tireless labor and ambition and a new
religion capitalism no wonder a German
historian dubbed John Calvin the virtual
founder of America it makes sense that
Winthrop a manic us but accustomed to
setting lofty goals for himself would
then set lofty goals for the colony he
is about to lead a model of Christian
charity is the blueprint of his communal
aspirations it is a glimpse at what the
chief executive officer of the
Massachusetts Bay Colony believed he and
this grumpy few before him were supposed
to shoot for come dry land two words he
says justice and mercy and then I'm
gonna skip ahead a little bit to get to
on the heart of that sermon Christ and
His Church make one body
Winthrop says paraphrasing Paul
furthermore claims went through the
ligaments of this body which knit
together our love then he quotes Paul's
letter to another church in Galatia bear
ye one another's burdens and so fulfill
the law of Christ keep that one in mind
bear ye one another's burdens and so
fulfill the law of Christ you can think
about that during the when you're paying
for the bailout
the body of Christ connected with the
ligaments of love is not merrily pretty
poetry or spiritual mumbo-jumbo to
Winthrop and his people it is a bond of
marriage between him him with a capital
H and us which is to say it is a
contract remember Winthrop was a lawyer
that might be why the final paragraphs
of Christian charity the ones that will
be the most quoted later on are the most
profound given the task of outlining a
binding legal pact between Massachusetts
and God Winthrop comes alive we are he
writes entered into covenant with him
for this work and I will make of thee a
great nation God had promised Abraham
the price of such greatness as cottons
farewell sermon already reminded the
colonists is a great big headache their
duties rights Winthrop are these now the
only way to provide for our posterity is
to follow the counsel of Micah to do
justly to love mercy to walk humbly with
our God Micah an Old Testament prophet
said that God's words do good to him
that walketh uprightly as for God's
promise to the sinners the mountains
shall be molten under him and the valley
shall be cleft as wax before a fire
failures of justice and mercy and
humility
Winthrop warns will cause God to surely
break out in Wrath against us
Winthrop uses a word to describe such a
calamity that must have been especially
terrifying if he was delivering this
sermon at sea shipwreck the only way to
avoid this shipwreck he says is to be
knit together in this work as one man
went through then utters one of the most
beautiful sentences in the English
language we must delight in each other
make others conditions our own rejoice
together mourn together labor and suffer
together always having before our eyes
our commission and community in the work
our community as members of the same
body I'm a reasonably happy-go-lucky
person with a serviceable sense of humor
and a nice enough apartment in New York
the most exciting city in the world
no offense once I decided to devote
years of my life to deciphering the
thoughts and feelings of the dreary
religious fanatics who founded New
England nearly four hundred years ago I
was often asked at parties by my fellow
New Yorkers the obvious question what
are you working on when I would tell
them a book about Puritans they would
often take a swig of the beer or bourbon
in their hands and reply it with either
a sarcastic fun or disdainful why at
which point depending on my mood I would
either mumble something about my
fondness for sermons as literature or
mentioned taking my nephew to the
Mayflower replica waterslide in a hotel
pool in Plymouth
I would never answer it with the honest
truth namely that in the weeks after two
planes crashed into two skyscrapers here
on the worst day of our lives I found
comfort in the words of Winthrop when we
were mourning together when we were
suffering together I often thought of
what he said and finally understood what
he meant we were breathing city air and
the suit was composed of incinerated
glass and steel but also we knew
incinerated human flesh when the local
TV news announced that rescue workers
sorting through the rubble in search of
survivors were in need of toothpaste
half my block having heard that there
was finally something we could actually
do besides worry and grieve had already
cleaned out the most popular name brands
at the corner deli by the time I got
there so at the rescue workers
headquarters I sheepishly dropped off 14
tubes of Sensodyne the toothpaste for
sensitive teeth
we were members of the same body
breathing the cremated lungs of the dead
and hoping to clean the teeth of the
living um so I in there it's kind of sad
ending isn't it I'll oh I'll say this
this is a sort of kind of upbeat um I'm
talking I'll down later I'm talking
about Winthrop and and his fellow
colonists colonists despite their unruly
theology there sometimes hair-trigger
hate the fact that oh this doesn't work
this no no no
maybe this these English had affection
for the old Saxon word wheel it means
wealth and riches but it means welfare
and well-being too in Christian charity
Winthrop tells the colonists they must
partake of each other's strength and
infirmity joy and sorrow weal and woe
later on Roger Williams would write
there goes many a ship to see with many
hundred souls in one ship whose weal and
woe is called common and is a true
picture of a Commonwealth or a human
combination or society um I will I will
in the reading but there I'll take some
questions but I hope that sort of gets
that the thing that drew me to Winthrop
and this tiny little group of religious
fanatics living in mainly Boston and
then Rhode Island in the 1630s is is
their idealism and then this um this
beautiful these beautiful words about
you know sticking together as they are
about to embark on a voyage and perhaps
a crisis and on a personal note as
someone who came of age in the 80s and
and you know first heard Winthrop sermon
quoted to me by my then president who
often vote the city on a hill that would
be Reagan by the way
he called it you know shining city on
him because he was a little more showbiz
than Winthrop and it always just seemed
so ironic to me as someone who read the
whole sermon that's about you know
charity and generosity and remember that
verse I read to you about was it from
Paul about basically the gist of it was
that helping each other is God's law and
so the sermon is all is all about that
about sharing and if your brother needs
help if you love God and you can help
him you must help him and it's basically
Winthrop giving them this pep talk as
they're about to you know leave on this
very dangerous trip to start very
precarious new lives that they're really
going to have to stick together and
they're going to have to help each other
and when you know the former president
would invoke that this speech that's all
about charity and generosity you know on
the while gutting programs like you know
Housing and Urban Development and
sending maybe millions of people into a
life of homelessness and cutting school
lunch programs and I just found that a
little ironic and maybe my chapter on or
you know that part of our history and
how this speech was interpreted by you
know the person it's really most
identified with is perhaps a little
footnote on that fun period of our
history so I don't know if all of this
is self-explanatory but if not I will
take some questions if you have them Oh
a person will bring you a microphone
okay they're about 20 minutes of
questions so if you just raise your hand
we'll get you a mic hi
I would of course I had something
prepared and take away with that um I
was seeing her just crying because I'm
thinking gosh that woman talks just like
Sarah Bell because we listen to you all
the time after we read your books and
then listen again uh-huh and it's
wonderful but my question is when when
really it was there a point or I know
points are often windows when you turn
to writing about history you expect to
it before but if you could do that again
for me now oh when you die because I
love when you go back and forth into
rock I love when you Nancy right after a
wonderful description of Todd Robert
Todd Lincoln or whatever so uh-huh when
did I start writing about history really
just working on this American life and I
was doing various kinds of stories and
did one driving the Trail of Tears
my sister drove it and I rode in the
passenger seat because I can't drive and
we made a documentary about about that
trip and that was the first story where
I worked on something historical and
that story just really changed my life
so ever since then that's mostly what I
want to do oh thanks um I just liked
there was just so much drama in conflict
and and contradiction and I I just like
the whole process in the researching
process and also to tell you the truth
as a reporter I was Tara of I mean I
still kind of am one sometimes but I'm
kind of a tear
Abell reporter in terms of interviewing
a person who's living because I don't
like to pry actually it's a really you
know you'll notice that it that if
you're an interviewer you're either
being a bad person or a bad reporter or
some like point in between but you can't
be a great person and a great reporter
you either have to like press your point
and dig for the dirt or if you're a good
person you go okay you don't want to
talk about that that's fine I totally
understand that's how I am as a reporter
so there was something about them just
dead people I was just better with them
okay
that's really loud this is a question
about a character in the book and Anne
Hutchinson mm-hmm was she a little bit
crazy and really thought she heard
voices was she showboating and why would
she bring that up when she's apparently
about to be acquitted let's see yes yes
yes and she liked the sound of her own
voice to backtrack and Hutchinson is a
[ __ ] what do I want to say about her I
mean she's very fascinating figure and
and she liked Roger Williams one of the
other characters in the book both of
them were kicked out of Massachusetts
and you know escaped to Rhode Island
Williams first and Hutchinson later and
she was the daughter of a minister who
homeschooled her she was one of those
homeschooled students
and so um at home she basically received
the best possible education you know an
English girl of the 17th century could
get which is to say not an official one
with you know teachers and libraries and
stuff so she's you know she's a groupie
of John cotton the great minister and
when he emigrates to America comes to
Boston to be the minister in Boston she
and her family and that being her
husband and her 15 children she was a
very fertile woman uh they came and
followed cotton and and she started
having these prayer meetings ladies
prayer meetings in her home these are
incredibly common than and now I went to
one as a child and and at first she
would just have the ladies over and they
would talk about Cotton's
sermon the other day and and she would
lead them to discussion of that but but
she slowly starts just sort of winging
it and kind of preaching essentially and
first of all you can't be a Puritan
minister without a degree in divinity
and she doesn't have that secondly kind
of a woman that's also ixnay on the omen
way and not only is she talking to women
more and more they're coming to her
house in droves and men are coming to
including the the young twenty
six-year-old governor who was Winthrop
was voted out in this very interesting
fellow named Henry Bain the younger was
elected and he becomes kind of her best
friend and so all these people are
coming to her house and she's telling
them that John cotton and her
brother-in-law are the only ministers
worth listening to and all the others
are crap I'm paraphrasing but and that
and her followers start going into all
the churches in the colony and and
heckling the ministers and making
trouble and the colony is just like in
disarray these are the most argument
into bickering people in the best of
times
Massachusetts is always about to you
know spin off into a million splinter
groups anyway and and
is just the root of this huge rift that
is breaking this people apart and so
she's held before the magistrates before
Winthrop and the other judges and put on
trial and she outwits them she basically
says I don't think I've done anything
illegal they say you know your phone
fomenting dissent essentially and you
it's illegal for you to have these huge
gatherings in your house and then she
has a scriptural scriptural answer for
everything they throw at her you know a
verse about older women instructing the
younger woman and so anyway she
basically acquits herself until the
moment she doesn't because she has an
audience her audience is the most
important powerful men of the day and
she outsmarts them out argues them and
then in a moment she just kind of loses
her head and is so drunk on the sound of
her own voice
she starts you know saying what she
believes she's saying things like God's
talking to her and that she's filled
with the Holy Spirit we're used to that
kind of talk from you know evangelicals
now but to a Calvinist this was um
distasteful and blasphemous and she and
someone even mentions they heard her
give a prophesy once a witch like
prophesy the W word is invoked in and
basically she digs her own grave in' and
this gets her thrown out and
excommunicated and so was she crazy it
depends on whether you think a human
being can hear the voice of God if you
think a person who hears the voice of
God is crazy she was if you think that
person is a prophet perhaps she was that
but she was definitely like a very
singular person and the thing I love
about writing about her and Williams
whether you agree with all of their
beliefs or not some of them a little
eccentric
I'm fascinated just how much they stuck
out because you know all
things I talked about before the the
Puritan love of community which is so
beautiful that is there that is there's
a dark side to that which is everyone
has to agree to agree and anyone who
disagrees is booted out or you know
worse like one guy gets his ear sliced
off for speaking out against the
magistrates and so the thing I love
about Hutchinson and Williams is that
they stand tall they're not afraid of
anyone but God and they say sometimes
like really crazy stuff but they believe
it and and they they just don't Chum
they don't apologize for what they
believe and they you know speak out I'm
probably too too much I'm sure they're
pretty annoying people really but
their's they have a kind of freedom that
no one else around them seems to have
that that I find kind of charming they
were just born you know they were just
born too early like they really should
have been on like MSNBC or something all
those all those people all those people
yakking it up all day long in cable news
they would all have been booted out of
Massachusetts
here okay
um thank you Sarah for leaving New York
to come visit us that was nice of me
wasn't it miss berry it's very nice of
you this actually goes back to your last
book assassin vacation okay I was
wondering what your favorite part of the
musical assassins was my favorite part
of the musical assassins I guess it's
probably the duet of John Hinkley and
squeaky Fromme when they sing that love
song and it's a love song to Jodie
Foster and Charles Manson and that you
know the line ISM I will do anything for
your love you can think about that for a
second but I mean another two you know
those people are I think we can say
insane without you know well I'm sure we
can be sued in Britain but here we can
say they're probably insane but but
there's a there's a real not respect but
kind of empathy that Sondheim has for
these most of them lunatics you know
that I don't know if you can justify
other than to say I mean it's something
I definitely try to do and think about
and I think it's probably something I
learned working with Ira Glass working
on this american life because Ira Glass
I mean believes in the educational power
of empathy that you can learn more about
someone not if you try to like them but
if you just try to understand where
they're coming from and there's
something about that song between those
two lunatics that are they believe what
they believe and if you want to find out
why someone would try and do something
so horrific maybe it's worth knowing why
knowing that person's motivations you
don't have to condone it
not at all just um there's something to
be said for
empathy and like what I've done here
tonight I've I read from you some of the
beginning bits and talked about the you
know some of the the beauty and and the
ideals of the Massachusetts Bay Colony
but I'm setting you up for some of their
less adorable actions that come later on
there's you know there's their various
violent crackdown there's a genocide and
one person I was talking to yesterday
said she felt kind of swindled once she
got to the you know Pequot Massacre and
700 Pequot the English burn alive 700
men women children and she's like why
did you do that you made me like him and
then you know that happened and I was
just confused I was like well what would
you bet be better to just start with the
mass murder not not good from a showbiz
point of view certainly but also like
aren't aren't all unspeakable acts
created by people and like by humanizing
them first then their actions later on
the slaughter and all that seems to me
all the more horrific and I don't
remember what your question was
I'm sure I answered some question in
there uh I mean you know when you are
watching your for Holi following the
presidential campaign you're used to
knowing answering the questions thank
you
yeah I love all your books but I think I
love you travelogues the best yeah
because they're the educational they
have a strong sense of sort of
patriotism in them and a strong sense of
sort of love of history are you planning
anything like that again something
that's really kind of a pure to have a
log something closer to assassination
vacation do you have a problem with
Calvinism this kid um I don't know we'll
see I mean I'm thinking about something
on the history of Hawaii and there are a
lot of like more travelogue kind of
aspects of that but um I don't know
we'll see I never know what I'm going to
do until I do it like there the writer
Inger in brown says there are two kinds
of writers the ones who write because
they have something to say and then the
ones who write because they find out
what they think and I'm definitely the
latter person it's hard for me to plan
so I can't really make any promises I am
done with Puritans if that makes you
feel better
oh hi aunt Fran and maybe there I I
never mind I found out kind of recently
that I'm descended from a couple people
from the Massachusetts colonies one guy
on the Mayflower
George Sewell which makes me a cousin a
Barack Obama and Reverend John Lathrop
which makes me cousin a Sarah Palin you
know what do you think these folks would
think about either of these hooks um I
don't know
I yeah I don't know is tool one of the
Salem judges I don't know what a 17th
century music teacher would think about
Sarah Palin
hmm I really don't know hello
I really has gone I was really
interested that you talked about the
dual meaning of the word Providence that
it was not only God's providing but also
being really thankful for whatever God
provided oh yeah I'm definitely a glass
half and the kind of person I remember
Thomas Jefferson and a lot of the other
founders people who are deists and very
far removed from the Calvinists often
spoke of Providence is there is there a
direct linkage is there a heritage there
is there are some connection between
Winthrop and these guys and Jefferson
later on um I don't know that there's a
I mean there isn't that it's a you know
I think it's part of English Protestant
tradition at that point like everyone
and his brothers mentioning Providence
and it's mentioned and the guy who
coined the term manifest destiny you
know he uses he throws in Providence in
like in that paragraph where he he coins
that term so there's no I don't think
there's a direct link from Winthrop to
Jefferson exactly though there are some
interesting correspondences between
Jefferson and Roger Williams not about
Providence but you know both of them
Roger Williams first obviously used the
term wall of separation in arguing for
this is this is a what a presidential
candidate would do I don't know is the
answer to your actual question not
giving the answer I'm giving the and
there's no you know there's no evidence
that Jefferson ever read Williams when
Jefferson calls for a wall of separation
between church and state but it is sort
of interesting that that it's kind of in
the air with the Puritans first of
course Roger Williams wants there to be
separation between church and state
because he doesn't want the state to
mess up his church and Jefferson was
kind of an
you know the other way around well
thanks for making history so much more
interesting than it was when I was in
high school Oh like that would be hard
I'm curious if doing this research
affected in any way your spirituality or
your sense of God or your beliefs um no
I don't believe in God but I'm
interested in people who do I like I
mean not just people who believe in God
be and I don't believe in God I'm
interested in writing about people who
are not like me I'm also interested in
reading about people who are not like me
because that's sort of to me the joy of
reading and of writing because I'm
actually it's not that I'm a boring
person but I live what would seem
probably to other people a kind of
boring life in a way it's very pleasant
my life and thus not terribly dramatic
and like these people you know they're
getting on first of all I wouldn't step
on a boat for I can't go take the ferry
to weehawk and I hate boats so much
right there I'm interested you know and
there on those like little tiny cruddy
ships for weeks and weeks so that they
have me there and then you know like I
not to brag but I would not set 700
people on fire but I love I love writing
about them I mean it's interesting to
try and figure out because most of us
are like that and like if you read the
newspaper every day if you're like me
you just like read it thinking like who
would do this you know and so part of I
guess writing for me is writing about
people with whom I do not identify most
of the time including the ones who
believe in God sir could you say
something about or more if you would
please about this notion of American
accept
and particularly that sense I mean if
you feel it kind of in this campaign the
notion of America has this
responsibility Lotus beware this gets
this shining something to the world in
the experience of the early
Massachusetts colony was that
exceptionalism content to stay at home
or was it always some sort of I have to
take it someplace else to somebody else
you know expansionist as opposed to I'm
happy being here by myself um yeah I do
I think um well they certainly I mean
they certainly believed in themselves as
that they were God's new chosen people
and they pretty much thought any place
that got them was lucky to have them and
you know as they as they spread out as
they as they settle Connecticut as they
settle you know further and further west
their presence was seen as inherently
good I think I mean one reason Roger
Williams gets kicked out of
Massachusetts is that he questions
whether they have that Massachusetts has
the right to be there to that land
because when Williams found what would
become Rhode Island he gets the
Narragansett permission and John cotton
is so flummoxed by this this idea you
know that he thinks it it is God's plan
to you know subdue the earth and they
are the people to do that
there's just that's another reason I'm
fascinated by them because that there
there's their sense of self-worth and
self-esteem collectively I mean it's
something that we inherited from them as
a country and it's really difficult to
escape I mean I even talk about how I
still kind of buy into it this notion
that were God's new chosen people and as
I mentioned I don't even believe in God
but this notion of ourselves is so
powerful
it's in it so it's very difficult you
know to escape and when when when I
really started working on this book was
after Reagan's funeral and Sandra Day
O'Connor was reading a model of
Christian charity at the National
Cathedral not so far from here and she
got to the part where it says the eyes
of all people are upon us and she was
reading that you know recall the funeral
happened just right after the Abu Ghraib
photos came out and the eyes of all
people were upon us and what did they
see you know they saw he saw that girl
in fatigues standing in front of a
pyramid of naked prisoners with her
thumbs up and the thing that that
Winthrop and cotton and their peers had
that we have sort of lost was that
Winthrop and cotton um the fear of
failure and to Winthrop the city on a
hill wasn't just a beacon of hope it was
some that there that they could fail and
failure to them was to disobey their God
and their God had commanded them to take
care of one another and the just that
fear of failure is inherent within
cotton sermon and Winthrop sermon so
it's they're basically on day one of
American exceptionalism what if we mess
up let's try not to mess up oh my god
what if we mess up and I think we've
lost that mirror a little bit as a
country like a you know I mean I guess
that's one reason I wanted to write this
book because it I think it's something
it's you know like I don't know what
your flaws are I'm pretty well aware of
mine and I do try and you know if you
have any kind of self-awareness you try
and you know compensate or at least be
aware of your faults and the American
exceptionalism the idea that America is
inherently good and I do believe
strongly that we inherited this idea
from Massachusetts Bay it means that if
we do it it's good
and I don't find this opinion to be
particularly christ-like to say nothing
of particularly logical again I can't
remember what your question was can can
you actually this young man has been I'm
holding his hand up uh distracting me
yes sorry that's okay
can you um I'm I'm not such a big fan of
reading really um every time I look at
one of your books I noticed that it has
a little figurine on the front and I'm
just wondering why do you always use
figurines why do I always use figurines
on the cover
well the photographer who makes the
covers he his name is David Leventhal
and he your name is David - well my
friend David and all of his photographs
are Polaroids large scale Polaroids of
toys frequently vintage toys and the
reason I'm drawn to them and the reason
I think they're good covers for my books
is there's a kind of like I love how he
combines these playful things these toys
with a kind of moodiness and a kind of
very moody lighting you know so there's
both a sense of play and an ominous a an
ominous sense of foreboding at the same
time which is how I pretty much view the
world and
it's how I write my books and how I tell
my stories both of those two things so
that's pretty much why and also he lets
me use them which is also an important
step and getting them onto the cover the
permission so high and low um thank you
for asking though I hope I'm you know
I'm work with them kids and writing and
reading and everything and I feel like a
lot of kids especially boys they get you
know they're told the reading is just so
great you should be reading and then if
you read something like oh I don't know
a comic book or a joke book um people
put that down no not at your house
that's good because because I hope I
hope I hope you you decide to read more
and find ways to enjoy it and just read
the things you like and it doesn't
matter what they are because I guess I
just hope that for you because I hope
that for anyone because for me I think
of myself as a reader before I'm a
writer and it's one reason I wanted to
write about these people in particular
is because for all their faults and
there are many they loved to read and
they loved words and writing and and you
know they were pioneers basically who
have to like grow their own food and
build their own houses and you know they
did this while they were doing this they
were writing books and letters and
journals and like you wouldn't believe
and they had just barely finished
building their houses and they start
building Harvard because they want they
believe in education as much as anything
except for God you know and so the thing
I love about them is they do have this
they have they have this love of of
words and I hope that comes to you
because it can be a reading can just be
such a comfort I think and in a
sometimes uncomfortable world but thank
you for your question and I I wish you
much reading ahead
um thank you all for coming